the dinner to mark a century of prime
ministers living at checkers is unlikely
to be the cheerful celebration the
mansion's trustees were hoping for four
of the living premieres cameron brown
blair and major have turned down their
invitations that leaves just boris
johnson and theresa may to glare at each
other the last time the two met there
was for the chequers cabinet summit on
the eu negotiations johnson who was
foreign secretary resigned shortly
afterwards along with david davies
ultimately helping to bring about mrs
may's downfall from office
whatever the tensions between them all
prime ministers have come to love the
country house that goes with the job
what they call this house of peace was
first given to the nation after world
war one by lord lees one of lloyd
george's ministers and his rich american
wife explicitly for the rest and
recreation of her prime ministers
for years chequers was used for just
that relaxation with its tennis court
rolling grounds and swimming pool and
for private entertainment of cronies and
political allies
a keen artist winston churchill is said
to have taken his brushes to improve the
depiction of a mouse on an oil painting
by rubens hanging on the wood paneled
walls
margaret thatcher usually spent
christmas there and like to use visits
to what she called checkers church for
impromptu sound bites
[Applause]
early in the job a bruised and over made
up tony blair had to get special
permission from the trustees to use it
for work a tv interview after labour
accepted a million pound donation from
formula one
since then an invitation to checkers has
become the biggest honor the prime
minister can bestow on visiting foreign
leaders
blair held his final meeting with
outgoing president clinton there
angela merkel liked the buckinghamshire
countryside so much she asked for a
repeat visit
president xi was so taken by the beer in
the nearby plough pub that he joked
about buying it
john major often tells how he turned up
with boris yeltsin before opening time
and the landlord refused to believe the
russian president was banging on the
door
theresa may did her best to preserve
decorum when she entertained the
unpredictable donald trump in the house
and garden
the taxpayer contributes 916 000 pounds
a year towards the upkeep of checkers
but the prime minister has to pay for
food drink and entertainment themselves
some of them including boris johnson
have complained about the cost of
playing the host
still most prime ministers and their
wives consider checkers to be one of the
best perks of the job john major's wife
norma even wrote a book about it
her husband isn't going but dame norma
will be at the centenary dinner tonight
perhaps trying to keep the peace between
boris johnson and mrs may